Brad Pitt and Jennifer Aniston have been  in touch since his high-profile split  from Angelina Jolie it's comme si si a  source close to Brad tell zg they're  communicating and that they are friends  but nothing more adding quote they have  been in touch  they have been friendly back and forth  Brad and Jen divorced in 2005 after five  years of marriage  Brad Matt Angelina on the set of mr. and  mrs. Smith in 2004 they Wed in 2014  before splitting last fall  Jen told ET more than two years ago she  was over people pinning her against  Angelina I think it's it's time people  stop with that petty BS and just start  celebrating great work and stop with the  petty kind of silliness  it's just tiresome and old like an old  leather shoe the former friend star is  currently happily remarried to Justin  Theroux I got a sweet pink line man yeah  you